I'm Margot Robbie and I'm Sasha Ronan
and I'm going to doing the wired
autocomplete interview are these real
people become dead
he's my hobby British mango are you
British I am NOT I am Australian ding
ding ding is America Robbie Harley Quinn
who's that I am NOT Harley Quinn but I
play Holi Quinn all right that's your
name is Margot Robbie enjoys for Ryan to
him
do I look like someone in transformers
maybe maybe they just want you to be in
transform maybe maybe you should be a
transformer oh I could have played that
is Margot Robbie alive when do people
yeah I'm alive is murder Robbie attached
to I'm not a tattoo artist I'm a person
who owns a tattoo gun and dance tattoos
but there's no artistry involved what's
been your worst tattoo the one I spelled
incorrectly it was on Suicide Squad we
were doing squad tattoos on each other
we're spelling sk w ad and i terrible
how to pronounce Saoirse Ronan it's
actually it's so it's Saoirse but it's
easier for Americans and English people
to say Saoirse or Sasha what was the
difference
Saoirse is how Irish people say and how
to Americans it Saoirse kind of a sad
thing okay um how to Saoirse Ronan so
Saoirse Ronan
yeah just explain that just yeah how
tall is social ruinin visa sec I'm
twelve foot nine was so Sirona
in Twilight now I wasn't could've been
one of the werewolves does Saoirse Ronan
have siblings now I don't only child
yeah was Margot Robbie in damn to copy
no I was not in Downton Abbey but I
would have been rad was mega Robbie
nominated for an Oscar I was with my
fellow Oscar nominees certiorari shake
crowd was mad Robbie really skating in I
Tanya yes I was
although a lot of what you see is a
skate
because even with my skating a
professional could do it better
yes I skated a lot nice on you this
movie's a mess so I was I was in a soap
opera in Australia coordinators for
three years and it was wonderful is
Saoirse Ronan Irish that's why we guest
sure um is Saoirse Ronan married I wish
no is Saoirse Ronan in Game of Thrones
no the dragon ah dragon really cute my
dog is Saoirse Ronan on Instagram I had
no I'm not Saoirse Ronan American
technically yes as well I was born
you're born here is Saoirse Ronan vegan
know as let's say you just ordered
chicken tenders I happen pescetarian
though basically since March you know
chicken is yeah I know that but I'm
trying to be pescetarian know how Margot
Robbie net mm ah
it's a it's a it's probably a story too
long to tell right now but honestly you
could just google maka will be on Ellen
and probably um like the whole long
story how old is Margot Robbie I'm 28
although I see on the internet a lot of
people being like 28 more like 38 I'm
like oh I mean I can show you my birth
certificate I really am how was America
Robbie discovered I wasn't discovered as
much as I forced my way onto a job
essentially because I just wouldn't stop
calling FremantleMedia which is the
company that runs Mavis hello Margot
Robbie Brooklyn accent how how Margot
Robbie Brooklyn ah how that makes no
sense
no it doesn't how am i well yes yeah the
short answer is that pretended to have
fake nails
how to get married girl Robbie waves
much like hair waves
I knew that do it myself I do I just
have it in a plaque the night before and
take it out what is Saoirse Ronan
doing now yes what is Saoirse Ronan
'he's
age how you forget my age office
not you 24 yeah thanks that was the best
year of my life so far
well I'm sure there's other quick one I
even really loved 23 and 25 like
someone's yeah yeah yeah I'm a writer
what was social Ronan's first movie um I
could never be your woman which was a
film with Michelle Pfeiffer oh I really
came in that was actually quite good
time
what color are social Ronan's eyes black
they're beautiful blue clue what Saoirse
means freedom oh my god freezing moral
Liberty I learned things today yes I do
feel changed after that I do I do and I
feel like we've bonded on a level that
we just had in the movie Mary Queen of
Scots which you should go and favored by
the way thanks behinds word bye